springing Tim Kelly Sean Dallas Morning
News more importantly the star of around
the horn Tim good morning how are you
good morning and if you want to just
read my entire column I'm fine with that
I think their listeners are fine with
that is it better than having you on
then I just read your column I would be
a hell of a lot better but since you
went the other direction yeah they were
you know that 11-game streak not only
made back Rookie of the Year and made
this team think they had their future it
made Tony Romo a broadcaster because
without that 11 game winning streak Romo
would have eventually got his job back
but they couldn't bench dak the way they
were winning but since then you're right
that's what I wrote about their 11 and
11 they've gone back to being the very
average Jason Garrett team that we've
seen for so many years and it just seems
like offensively everything has to be
perfect or it doesn't work if they miss
D it doesn't work if they miss Tyra
Smith it doesn't work and even part of
it was Dez had 300 yard games in that 11
game winning streak and he never had a
hundred yard game all last year he never
had one since so once he kind of
disappeared as a as a threat then you
know a lot of this stuff that works but
that Prescott went away I don't know
what the expectation level was in Dallas
because I saw anywhere from they could
win the division to they're going to be
a 7 & 9 team
III thought they would be an average
team I thought if they got to eight wins
maybe nine at the most that that would
be a good year for this to you I just
don't think they're a formidable team I
don't know if anything changes with that
but that was my feeling going into the
regular season do you see them as an
average team this year I picked them
seven to nine but to go 7 and 9 but of
the 10 people we had in the Dallas
Morning News selectors Fox thank you
very much for reading I was the only one
under 500 ok I think there were a couple
11 and 5 2 or 3 10 and 6 there's a bunch
of 18 8 and 9 and 7 and even the Vegas
odds rate and a half wins so they were
seen as
average but hey Zeke's back you know it
could go back to being a little like
2016 but I don't think very many people
around here thought they're gonna get
back to 12 and for 13 and 3 they just
thought they'd be good and obviously
they still could be but that first game
was not a great indication of being a
good team do you think dak Prescott is a
franchise quarterback no I think he's a
guy who you know that's gonna be the
hardest decision is that second contract
once you give a guy that you know I was
looking over the week yet derrick karr
Garoppolo Roethlisberger all had three
interceptions I think I think staff with
Utes or Monday night those are guys who
eat up a ton of your you know once you
get that second contract you're up
around 20 million dollars you eat up you
eat up the salary cap for your team that
doesn't count anything right now that's
why I think they've made such a big
mistake not being more aggressive in
free agency after that 13 and 3 season
and trying to follow the russell wilson
seattle mode hey let's win while we've
got a cheap non first-round pick at
quarterback let's load up around him and
they've done the complete other
direction let's try to just be young
everywhere let's not even go get our own
thomas and so i don't think that's
worked but as far as dak being a
franchise quarterback i mean that's what
this season is all about and i think
that's hard hard to call and i don't
think he's going to be a top 10
quarterback i think he's gonna be a top
1617 quarterback and then you got to
decide what you do with that well
because you got one more year with this
great contract and then after that yeah
you don't have to do anything after this
year you could if you had a great year
you could go ahead and move forward he's
got four years so there's there's
another year after this but yeah you the
clock is ticking on figuring out what to
do with him would you have kept Dez
Bryant at least for one more year no I
thought that decision made sense not
just for financial reasons
he'd had three straight years where he'd
gone below
a thousand yards and if you look up
receivers who do that they almost never
go back to being thousand yard receivers
but if I was going to do that I would
have done tried to do more than just say
okay well add Allan urns and Deonte
Thompson and we'll drop somebody in the
third round we'll just see what comes
out of that because they don't they
don't appear to have any idea what they
have a wide receiver what those guys can
do and most people think they don't have
much and I would agree with that
how much importance do you place on this
game Sunday night against the Giants you
know a lot obviously the NFL is the
great thing about the NFL is there are
many of these games so you got it you
got to get going quickly and one of
these teams is owing to the Giants
probably feel like they played pretty
well against a team that you know might
be really good Cowboys didn't play very
well against a team that I don't think
it's going to be very good even if there
were playoffs team last year so I yeah I
mean I think they got to feel like you
gotta gotta get going somewhere got to
beat the Giants if you could ask Jerry
Jones one question and he had to answer
it with complete honesty what would it
be
do you do you really truly believe your
decision to be general manager the last
25 years in hindsight was the right
thing to do and he'll say yes and but if
he answers but well his normal answer
would be yes but if he has to answer it
honestly he'd have to think about that
it feels like Jerry the owner has been
great Jerry the GM has been terrible
right which I've written about that many
times and if you think about it you
think about all the other teams and the
GM's we talk more about coaches on the
hot seat but there's GM's on the hot
seat all the time there's all kinds of
general manager changed in this league
Jerry and Steven Jones are never on the
hot seat whatever whatever they're doing
hey but hey if it doesn't work we'll try
something else
it's been 23 years since an NFC
Championship game and that's okay we're
not getting fired look Jerry
Jerry the owner would have fired will
circumstance Jerry the owner would have
fire yes Jerry the GM he's gotten rid of
six coaches I would think he would have
to have turned to the GM at some point
if he had one would he be willing to
turn this team over to a coach who had
total autonomy because obviously there's
a reason why Jason Garrett is still the
head coach because Jerry that's like
he's to know he didn't get sorry he
didn't give Parcells total autonomy but
he gave him more than anybody had had
since Jimmie Johnson and he didn't
really like that and it sort of worked
and it sort of didn't it didn't work in
the sense they didn't want any plows
capes the team got a lot better in those
four years before Parcells left
I don't think at 76 years old he wants
to take a step back and do that again in
fact he was asked some times in the last
month would he trade his Hall of Fame
jacket and status for a Super Bowl and
he said no let's keep that jacket it's a
pretty nice jacket so you know I mean he
wants to win and I truly believe he
wants to win but he understands what
it's like when he is not in the middle
of everything and he doesn't like it
yeah but he's can somebody tell him that
you're part of the problem with the
Cowboys that's what addressed the number
of times and even God he does not see it
that way he sees it as he and Steven are
willing to take risks that other GM's
who might be fired for these risks
wouldn't dare do so he thinks it's all
about their ability to take risks which
they do every year in the second round
and they do other places and he's got
that intent that that works and for now
there's no getting it out of it I know
you got your around the horn meeting is
that going on right now it's it's about
to commence
okay I'm not even sure who I'm playing
against today it doesn't matter - I did
tell you last time your honor you were
gonna lose to Jackie McMullen didn't I
think you nailed that yeah I did
because see I've already
today's episode yeah I already yeah and
I know who's gonna win but I know people
bet on this so I'm not going to say it
but yeah so I've already seen today's
episode and look you have one really
good line and you'll be proud of it I'm
just saying there's one really yeah one
good line but I don't think yeah yes yes
yes 10 1 yeah I wanted to ask you about
your one line why did you follow me over
the cliff with the Chargers going to the
Super Bowl
I picked the Chargers there the next
thing I know Dan tactic picks the
charges Max Kellerman takes the charges
Adam shine fix the charges everybody in
the world pick the charges oh well if I
had known that those guys had picked the
charges I never would have picked the
Chargers but Tim I didn't know you
picked the Chargers I mean I follow you
I follow your dating life but I do i
well you helped me follow your dating
life by the way is she still in the
picture yes you getting engaged have fun
today on around the horn okay thank you
okay that's Tim Couch on Dallas Morning
News columnist an around the horn star
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]